All right. People. It is November 30th, 2020,
we're almost into December. And I'm Dave Rubin.
This is the Rubin report direct message.
It was a long weekend holiday weekend, Thanksgiving weekend.
I know that most of you probably committed several misdemeanors and felonies by
getting together with family members,
perhaps crossing state lines may be even sharing the spoon
of a buffet style meal.
So I know a lot of you were probably on the run from the law right now.
You're probably in a car, you know, cops behind ya. They're hunting us down.
They're coming for us.
These more chronic authoritarian draconian laws that these dingbats
have, uh, tried to crush us with, but I don't think they're going to win.
And in case he can't tell people I'm in a very good mood this morning.
I am completely refreshed. I needed a couple of days just to, just to eat,
basically sleep, watch some TV and do pretty much nothing else.
And that's exactly what I did. We did a little gardening around here. We,
we just ate a obscene amount of food.
If you're not following me on, on Twitter or Instagram or whatever,
you can see the type of stuff that we're cooking around here.
And I think we're to work on a cookbook as well.
We've sort of had an idea for it for, for quite some time. Um,
so you can check out on Instagram Rubin report and on Twitter, Rubin record,
all that stuff. Uh, we did a little gardening. We watched airplanes.
David had never seen an airplane before we watched airplane.
And it's just like absolute perfection.
I would say naked guns still to me is the funniest movie of all time.
But we did watch a little airplane. That was great. And uh, Oh,
and then we watched Mandalorian and I know, you know,
I did a Q and a over the last week or so,
and I said that I wasn't loving Mandalorian.
It just didn't quite get me there yet. But finally,
the last two episodes they're getting there and to see a soca there in the way
they're linking the pre-calls with the originals and now in the new, well,
not the new universe, but the now universe, I guess you could say,
I thought that was pretty great too. So it was just,
I'm feeling good about life. I know the world is crazy. Uh, but uh, I think,
I think some good things are on the horizon.
I think a lot of people are really misjudging what's happening in the world
right now. And we're seeing a lot of people celebrate a little too early. Oh,
and we're not even going to do this story,
but I guess I should address the fact, Oh no, we are going to do this story.
I was about to, uh, to talk about Biden's foot, but we, we are,
we aren't doing Biden's foot. All right. So let's,
let's talk about lockdown stupidity because here in Los Angeles, it,
it continues to get worse and worse. One day,
I'm just going to be doing the show from, you know,
literally just be a dark room. I will have nothing.
They'll just be a spotlight on me and nothing else. Uh, because these lockdowns,
they, they just continue. So we'll start off with a,
a quote from the Los Angeles department of health. And well,
here we go.
As new COVID 19 cases remain at alarming levels and the number of people
hospitalized continues to increase a temporary Los Angeles County health
officer order will be issued to require additional safety
measures across sectors. Now,
before I get into the specifics of what they're asking us to do,
and I assure you, they're ridiculous, you're going to find out soon enough.
I just wanted to point out that as far as I know in the United States,
we don't have any hospitals that have been completely overrun.
We don't have any States that have been completely destroyed, Florida,
which has stayed open is not somehow a million times worse than
California, which has stayed closed.
We don't see massive outbreaks in homeless camps, encampments.
Now we got a lot of homeless encampments. I went to home Depot yesterday.
I had to drive under a bridge and there's literally now trolls under the bridges
because they all live under the bridges now. And they have massive encampments.
Obviously, no one,
they're not doing the things that would be best for personal hygiene and wearing
masks and everything else. But we don't see massive outbreaks there. I passed,
I passed a, a, I pass two hospitals yesterday, actually.
And they're both pretty much empty. Now, again, this isn't to say that COVID,
isn't real and we know it's real.
And we know that 99% of people roughly survive it.
And we know we've got vaccines coming out and everything else.
And whether they're rushing out the vaccines and whether you should take the
vaccine as a separate issue.
But the point is that these insane measures are just destroying people
lives and doing nothing else. And I look forward,
I predicted this on Twitter a couple weeks ago,
but I really believe that 2021 is going to be the year of the lawsuit.
P there are going to be so many class action lawsuit suits and,
and personal lawsuits going after the crash politicians who
manipulated science and did all sorts of things that they constitutionally are
not allowed to do. Uh,
but let's break down some of the numbers and some of the specific things that
you're allowed to do here, Los Angeles, let's throw it up.
This is very exciting.
Essential retail can be at 35% maximum occupancy.
Now I don't know what essential retail is. I mean, I guess if you need sneakers,
that would be essential, but like,
is buying like a hoodie not essential or like, what is essential retail?
They don't, they never tell you it doesn't matter, but okay.
35% now where'd they come up with that number? Now,
this is what I'm saying about how none of this is based in science,
like 35% at essential retail.
That sounds like something like they put some thought into it, but why not? 40%?
Why not? 45%? I don't know. Non-essential retail, whatever that is.
Non-essential retail. So is that a video game store? Uh,
so that would be at 20% maximum occupancy. All right.
You know, sounds sorta whatever, uh,
includes indoor malls at 20%. I mean,
most indoor mall has been failing for a long time.
They're usually at 10% occupancy if you've been to a mall lately. So 20%,
they'd be thrilled to have that personal care services at, uh,
can be at 20% maximum, maximum occupancy. So personal care,
I assume that's like getting your nails done, getting your toe toenails done,
maybe getting your haircut. So, okay. 20%.
And I'm sure those businesses will really thrive, right?
Like those people who own those small businesses,
that's going to really thrive when only one out of five of your little chairs at
your, at your nail salon or your foot specialist place. When that, uh,
when those chairs are, uh, all open, four out of five are open.
Libraries can be at 20% maximum occupancy,
okay. That not ever. I mean, again, these numbers they do.
They just make up these numbers.
Fitness centers operating indoors can be at 50%, uh, sorry.
Outdoors can be at 50% maximum occupancy.
Now remember most fitness places, most gyms your gym. Think about your gym.
Do they have an outdoor area? The gym that I used to go to, I,
I went to Equinox. I canceled it, but they had no outdoor area.
And now it just sits there. Absolutely empty, good, young, healthy,
vibrant people could be going to the gym indoors.
They could be taking their temperature outside.
They could be washing things off and sterilizing things,
but instead they've decided to destroy businesses.
Like most gyms don't have a just outdoor area for you to run around and play in.
Museums, galleries.
Zoos, and aquariums can be at 50% occupancy.
So what are they going to do with all the penguins? Okay. What are you going to,
you're going to slaughter half the penguins.
Is that what we're is that what we're doing now? I mean, really? It's this,
we're gonna have a big penguin roast at this point. 50% capacity.
I mean that again, it just makes no sense. Museums, galleries, zoos,
and aquariums. Let's try this. Museums, museums usually indoors,
mostly endorsed. Sometimes they have a little outdoor area to museum galleries,
usually indoors. Okay. Fine. Zoos outdoors. Right?
I've been to the LA zoo here in LA. Many times I've been to Safari park, uh,
which is the, uh, the San Diego zoo. They've got the whole Safari.
You're in a big Safari. It's outdoors.
Can you be there aquariums outdoors? For the most part, I know the lizards,
you know, they keep the lizards two doors.
The point is none of this makes sense.
Why would a museum that's indoors be at 50% capacity and an aquarium?
You see the point a and then here's my favorite mini golf batting
cages. Go-kart racing,
operating outdoors can all be at 50%. So
Schiller,
we've wrecked the livelihoods of restaurant tours and all sorts of people who
opened little shops and whatever they wanted to do with their lives.
But we're going to keep the go-cart thing going at 50%, you know,
just 50 freaking percent, uh, by the way,
this is all colored by the fact that right now,
they also are telling us that you can't have anyone else in your home.
That's right. You are supposed to until December 20th.
So this is three weeks basically. And then by the way,
they'll roll that right into Christmas. I mean,
they tried to Thanksgiving and now they want to destroy Christmas.
These people are evil. Do you get it yet? Uh,
but they wasn't nobody in your house. So I just want to be very clear.
They were about something because you guys know I'm a radical freedom.
Extremist. I'm breaking the laws right now. Michael,
will you please wave to the camera? Okay. That's one hand Connor, will you wait,
you see what's happening here?
People I've got floating hands in this room with me. The room is,
I'd say maybe 10 by 10. There's at least two, their hands in here. Okay.
At least what are you going to come and get me? Garcia? You like, Oh,
screw you people really. They're just awful.
But if you want to know how awful they are, I'd say, uh, Gavin Newsome, who is,
is our ridiculous governor here in California.
He hit peak Gavin Newsome awfulness,
and then Kamala Harris and went into peak Kamala awfulness because they put out
these insane tweets over the weekend, uh,
because they were talking about small business Saturday.
And here's the tweet from Gavin Newsome. I mean,
this is just incredible quote. Today is small business.
Saturday, California is home to over 4 million small businesses.
This holiday season shop safe and shop local to help support
our account economy and the over 7 million workers that help keep our small
businesses going. Okay.
Do you understand that Gavin Newsome
is the one who has closed all of the small businesses.
He has closed all of the small shops,
all of the small restaurants, all of these things.
And then he's also telling us that we should shop there while he's got these
people with their restaurants closed and boarded up the height of
hypocrisy. This, this guy is going to French laundry. The most,
one of the most expensive restaurants in the entire country.
I did this story last week. He was with 22 people. They were indoors.
They didn't have masks.
They spent $15,000 on booze,
$15,000 on booze.
That's about 750 bucks a person on booze.
And he has the goal as they shut down and destroy lives,
destroy your lives. They have the gall to tell you, Oh,
it also shop at the small businesses. Only.
The only thing is we closed all the small businesses right now.
Literally I can go about two miles away and go to target. Target is open.
But if you were to go to just the little store,
just the little store that I'd have some of the things that you might get at
target, say some, uh, holiday wrapping paper, some gifts,
trinkets, whatever it is, those stores are closed. And this,
this numb nut dingbat has the gall to say this,
but then the, uh, the presumed president delay.
And we'll get to the next story in a second.
Cause I think she's thinks she's going to be president. Uh, this is from, uh,
Kamala. She said, small businesses need our support.
Now more than ever before this small business, Saturday throughout the holidays,
please shop local and do your part to the backbone of our communities and our
economy. Again,
Democrats are the one one's destroying all of these businesses.
These people are, these people are liars and frauds.
They are not good people. If you don't see it yet, I, I, if I could smack you,
I don't know that we have the technology yet through the YouTube,
but I would just whack you just not a, not a full on bam, but just like,
you know, like you, you wake up already. These, these are not good people.
They must be voted out and they have,
they should have no authority to run anyone's life. And, and by the way,
I'm just not listening to any of their edicts.
Like I'm going to have people here. Look, look, I got a floating hand,
watch this floating in there's one floating hand.
Can I get another floating hand? Look at this. I got floating hands, like,
come and get me Garcetti, really come and get me. Let's see what happens, man.
Ugh, gross losers. Uh, but it's not just California.
That's completely insane. Vermont is actually, uh,
potentially equally as insane because now they've got school children
ratting out their parents. Yeah.
They literally want children to tell their teachers and administrators
at public schools. What the nature of their Thanksgiving holidays, where,
I mean, this is absolutely insane. This is, this is a story from the blaze.
The state of Vermont has announced that school children and their parents will
be questioned about the nature of their Thanksgiving gatherings.
After the kids returned to school and children and families that admit
to violating the state's rules against celebrating with another household will
be.
We're required to quarantine at home.
Do you see why we have a problem here?
People we are telling children that they should
rat out on their family members.
Did you little Johnny celebrate Thanksgiving with grandma? Sure.
She only has a couple of years to live and maybe she didn't want to spend her
last years alone in a dark room during Thanksgiving.
She wanted to take the risk and be there with her family.
And you could have socially distanced or done whatever else you want to rambly,
but we're the government and you better do what we say. God, it's insane.
I mean, kids ratting out parents. That's what they want.
That's what they want. And by the way, because, uh, you know,
obviously I hit the Democrats on this a lot.
The governor of Vermont is a Republican. His name is Phil Scott.
And he's the one that ordered the Vermont agency of education to execute this.
So most of these draconian laws, most of these ridiculous rat on your neighbor,
we're locking you down.
We're destroying small businesses while telling you to go to small businesses.
Most of it's coming out of Democrats, but Phil Scott, you're the, uh,
you're the prime I'm trying to, you know,
I've been saying that F bomb a lot of them on the show lately,
because I've been doing these special messages and I know you guys enjoy them.
I did a special messaged with my newsman glasses.
I did a special message to, uh, to Gavin Newsome.
I think I did to build a Blasio. And a lot of people are enjoying them. And the,
and the, you know, they get, they pick up some steam,
but I was trying to be nice there to Phil, to Phil Scott. Wasn't that,
what's his name in the office. That was Michael Scott.
But you see the same difference people. Anyway,
I have the glasses here and I'm thinking about doing one today, but I'm not,
I'm not sure yet. Cause I'm trying not to curse too much,
but really like the idea of children ratting on their parents.
Like how far are we from that to show me your papers, right? Like world war II,
Nazis people just walking down the street, show me your papers over.
We're going to take you away. It's just, it's just crazy. Um, all right, well,
speaking of crazy,
there's a 78 year old man who is the presumed president elect,
although I'm pretty sure it ain't gonna happen, but we'll see about that.
There's a lot of stuff going on there that the mainstream's not,
not talking about, not, not to talking about and they're not talking about it.
Um, but we got this 78 year old guy with dementia. And then on Saturday,
apparently he broke his foot. He fractured his foot while playing with his dog.
Now, normally, uh,
you would think a 78 year old man with a broken foot in dementia.
Maybe he shouldn't be the leader of the free world,
but let's put that aside for a sec. Uh, here's ABC news.
They said after initial x-rays were reassuring,
a follow-up CT scan showed that president elect Joe Biden has hairline
fractures in his foot following a fall. This weekend,
his doctor said Biden will likely need to wear a walking boot for several weeks.
You know, the boot, you know that boot, you see these people with the boot.
I don't know. I laugh every time I see the boot, something about that.
Boot just seems very funny to me, but okay, it's already started with Joe Biden.
It's like this, man. If, if, if he is sworn in on January 20th, which again,
I'm still not convinced is going to happen.
But if he is sworn in on January 20th,
the idea that he is going to be president for four years,
until he's 82 years old, he obviously has the beginnings of dementia.
He now has a broken foot and he's going to be in a boot and a broken foot.
You know what happens after the broken foot people? It's the broken hip.
And you know what happens to elderly people once they break the hip, okay?
We all know what this thing looks like. Like this is just the,
I don't know if they pushed them. I'm not, you know,
I'm not saying any of that happened.
Let's just say he tripped over the dog or something happened with the dog,
but this guy is not ready, is not, it's not ready. That's not the right word.
He is not fit to be president of the United States. And this is just a,
her in a way you think his team has got to be thrilled right now.
Cause they're like, Oh,
now we have the perfect excuse to never get them out there. Right.
We never have to get them out because we don't want them to be seen in the boot
limping like, like a lame dog. Right?
So instead we're just gonna hide him and we'll let Kamala do all the
talking. And man, she, you know, she is licking her chops,
just waiting for that 25th amendment to be called out and go,
I'm taken over. But I assure you people, if Biden is sworn in on January,
you know what, here we go. I'm going to make a bold statement. Michael,
coming to make a bold statement today. Bold statement. Here we go.
If Joe Biden is sworn in on
January 20th, 2021,
and he completes a four year term actually completes a four-year term.
I will retire. I will retire at the end of that term. That will be it.
I will disappear in just over four years,
four years in about a month and a half. And that'll be it.
That's how convinced I will just disappear from public life altogether.
I will delete all of my accounts and then you'll never hear from me again.
That's how convinced I am, that it ain't going to happen.
He will not be president for four years.
He either won't be president at all because of the election fraud and all that
kind of stuff. Um, which by the way, is gaining momentum.
We're not even really covering it that much today,
but it is actually gaining momentum.
And Giuliani was at a hearing in Arizona today.
They found some really bizarre stuff with these mid, you know, these late night,
1:00 AM to 6:00 AM vote dumps. I think in Pennsylvania, ran,
Paul was tweeting about it this morning. I mean,
there's just some stuff going on,
but I do not think that one way or another Joe Biden will not be president for
four years anyway. So he's got a broken foot on top of everything else.
And then I saw this clip this weekend, you know,
I try not to tweet on the weekends, but then, you know,
sometimes I accidentally get on there literally accidentally,
like you just open up my phone and my finger just goes through it. And I'm like,
ah, I'm in there. Um, or sometimes people send me some things,
but I thought this was just spectacular because this is four years ago basically
to the day.
This is right after Donald Trump was elected president and the Russians were
involved in the whole thing and it was very bad. Uh, and he was on Chris Hayes,
his show on MSNBC. And at first, when you see this clip,
Chris Hayes to me is a five-year-old,
who's dressed up like an adult with his fancy glasses to look like he's an
important person who knows what he's talking about. Uh,
but they talk about the wonderful ways that they could
overthrow the election of Donald Trump.
And I thought it would be worth showing you too when these people show when they
now tell you, Oh no, no, no, no, there's nothing we can do.
And you must obey the results of the election,
but they were singing a different tune four years ago.
Here's the clip from Ms and BZ.
I think there are people who are pushing very hard and think that, um,
because of some of the constitutional perils of the emoluments clause, uh,
because of the popular vote margin, because of, um, uh, fundamentals,
they think threat to liberal democracy that the,
that electors should be persuaded and pressured on Monday to,
to part with what their pledges and vote and vote against Donald Trump. Yes,
they absolutely should do that. Absolutely.
I believe right now that there are electors,
but only 38 of them who have a conscience or who are worried about a man who
won't attend the daily security briefings who, uh,
who we now know Russia was trying to help get elected. I mean,
can you imagine that this is if you are, I had been running for office and they,
they showed that the Iranians were somehow involved in helping you or me get
elected. What would happen to you or me, Chris? I'm just curious what happen.
It would be a totally all right. People I'm as serious as those two,
I've got thick, grim glasses on.
So you know what I'm about to say has a lot of weight. Okay. Um, yeah. What is,
what is Michael Moore? Michael Moore, uh, go to the gym,
take a couple of days off bread for God's sakes. Um, he says, uh,
electors with a conscience that they're the ones that are supposed to flip the
election.
And he obviously got help from the Russians God,
these people are absolutely patently absurd, patently,
absurd,
everything they said four years ago is now the reverse of what they're saying.
Yeah.
And that again is why you really shouldn't be for a team in and of itself,
because then you're just going to flip constantly.
You should try to have some basic set of principles that you can apply and then
you go, Oh, well maybe I want to scale back power.
This is what I tell you guys all the time. Right?
And I'm a guy with thick rim glasses. So, you know,
I know what I'm talking about.
What you want to do in a healthy society is scale back the power so that when
the guy who's the real bad guy gets in, he can't do that much bad.
And when the guy who you like your good guy, right?
Your hero when he gets in the trade off is he can't do everything you want.
And that allows us to have that healthy tension between conservative and
liberal and left, right. And red, blue Democrat, Republican, and the rest of it.
Um, I'll take the glasses off for the rest of this. Anyway,
I thought it was worth, uh,
it was worth showing you guys that there is just such a series of,
of stupid things happening. Um, but that's what we're here for.
That's what we're here for it, by the way,
I wasn't even going to do a show today, uh, because we just, uh,
we hired our new director Connor and he's here in person for the first time.
So I know over the last couple of weeks,
we've had a couple of little technical glitches.
We've been doing a lot of stuff on the fly and everything else,
but we've now got our full team here in Los Angeles. And, uh,
you know what, let's just show them the floating hands.
One more time just to prove I'm here with human beings. Okay.
I know I'm going to, I'm going to I'm racking up fines left and right over here,
real people in this room, we're all going to be okay.
We're making decisions for ourselves.
I think we're going to go out further because they were going to go out for
lunch. We can't go out for lunch. We're going to sit outside for lunch.
That's what we're gonna do today. Uh, all right guys, uh, we're,
we're back five days a week. This week originally, as I said,
I was going to only plan to do this show three days a week,
but the world just won't let me have a day. Uh, by the way, we posted a part,
one of my new interview with Douglas Murray Douglas is basically
the clearest thinker around, uh, highly recommend you watch it.
I got his take on everything happening in America. He was in America,
actually stayed with us for a couple of days, uh, here at the house,
but he was in America where he, he went to Trump rallies.
He traveled with Antifa. He was at, uh, some of the election stuff and got,
you know, as someone from the UK got just like an insider's view of America.
So we talk about that. Uh,
he also opines on this story that you probably heard about a penguin random
house, which is my publishing company, by the way,
there they're the people that publish don't burn this book,
the Canadian imprint, uh, they were,
they were having all sorts of problems because Jordan Peterson's new book is
coming out. And some of the,
some of the children who work there were very upset and they were crying because
Jordan's a white supremacist and the rest of it,
which of course is the reverse of truth. And it shouldn't matter, uh, whether,
whether an author is controversial or not,
because it's about how many books can this person sell and everything else.
So we get his feelings on that and much more.
So clip one is up and then the rest will be out throughout the week.
And of course the full episode is up on Rubin report.com already. Uh,
don't forget to subscribe to the channel here. We've got a busy day.
Hope you're good. And, and I just,
one last thing I think everything's going to be okay.
I can't really explain why, but I, I sent something good this week.
Today's Monday, by the time I do this show on Friday,
I think we're going to have some good news people.
That's the Dave Rubin prediction. I've never been wrong before,
so we'll see what happens. All right. That's it.
See you tomorrow.